all right I'm Dave Rubin and welcome to
another Friday Round Table Extravaganza
joining me today is the host of the
Michael Knowles show on The Daily wire
and author of many non-new York Times
bestsellers Michael Knowles and host of
the right report and former CIA Ops
officer Brian Dean Wright gentlemen
welcome to the Reuben report
excellent to be with you both thank you
for having me so glad to be here brother
uh Michael I'll start with you because
do you take offense I mean you've
written many books as far as I know
they're all non-new York Times
bestsellers but in some ways I actually
meant that as a compliment I appreciate
it no I I wear it as a badge of honor
now I did not uh the first time this
happened to me my book didn't have words
so I said okay I'll take it on the arm
literally did not have words you wrote a
book with no words and it sold I don't
know by the way 50 000 copies can I
break some news on your show right sure
sure on this front so I had one book
with words one my first book my greater
magnum opus without words
I have just received a word that my
first foreign translation will now be
published imminently and it will be the
Hungarian translation of reasons to vote
for Democrats coming out within days
so to be clear the book with no words
will be translated into Hungarian they
are furiously translating the spaces and
the gaps into the Hungarian language
that's correct let me call my friends at
the CIA I think we can get some other
languages for you we'll we will bust
this thing open man it's going to be a
huge deal everywhere well that's exactly
thank you that's exactly why I wanted to
have you both on for political insight
and a little Insider stuff on CIA and
intelligence and all that because uh
that seems to be what everything has
been about over the last couple weeks
between this now new the 87th Trump
indictment and just all of the political
stuff in these primaries that's heating
up and big Tech yada yada yada everyone
gets it so I thought we would start
today uh with some Tucker Carlson stuff
and we're going to go through Trump and
DeSantis and Pence and a whole bunch
more but the big thing of the week was
Tucker Carlson at this Blaze Forum
effectively ended the career certainly
the candidacy of former vice president
Mike Pence take a look sorry Mr vice
president have you I know you're running
for president you are the threat you are
distressed that the ukrainians don't
have enough American tanks every city in
the United States has become much worse
over the past three years drive around
there's not one city that's gotten
better in the United States and it's
visible our economy has degraded the
suicide rate has jumped public filth and
disorder and crime have exponentially
increased and yet your concern is that
the ukrainians a country most people
can't find on a map who've received tens
of billions of U.S tax dollars don't
have enough tanks I think it's a fair
question to ask like where's the concern
for the United States in that well it's
not my concern
Tucker I've heard that routine from you
before but that's not my concern
I'm running for president of the United
States because I think this country is
in a lot of trouble
wow it's not his concern now look I
tried to give him the benefit of the
doubt on Twitter I said he slightly
misspoke because I think what he meant
by it's not my concern may have been a
little bit more towards the the tanks in
Ukraine rather than the cities of the
United States of America
but okay uh Brian he reads to me as a
1994 Prime Time season five Simpsons
caricature of a republican I don't think
it flies in 2023 what do you think oh
not at all look had he said something to
the effect of hey look I've been to
Ukraine I've spoken to a variety of
different officials there and what I
know to be true is that the Russian
government are using these Christian
Orthodox leaders to manipulate the
Ukrainian people that's why I'm
concerned about you know the the
Christian leaders
um or not you know they're they're being
used by the Russians he could have
explained his position but he didn't he
just said yeah I talked to a guy there's
nothing big going on there and then he
just bumbled his answers so I'll tell
you you were absolutely right I think he
pretty much ended his candidacy at that
point what a terrible answer when we all
know that this country is struggling
what an awful way to respond
Michael do you see some of this as a
sort of generational Rift within the
Republican party like I personally
happen to be more in line with Tucker I
don't know I'm if I'm quite totally as
isolationist as I think he is but I'm
pretty much on the libertarian side of
this thing I sense that you probably are
that it feels like the old Guard versus
the new guard that that sort of is what
it boils down to in a way
it's generational in terms of the voters
right now the younger voters are much
more likely to be on the Tucker side of
this than on the Mike Pence side almost
certainly but it's not generational in
terms of the political figures don't
forget the Tucker side is broadly
embraced by Donald Trump who is older
than anybody in America other than Joe
Biden the Tucker side is embraced by Pat
Buchanan who is like 500 years old the
Tucker said has a long tradition on the
right and that tradition went away for
the past 30 or so years but it's come
back and it's come back with a vengeance
and so the the people who are now
articulating this view that we need to
constantly be involved in Wars all
around the world with no particular
strategic objective other than just kind
of being there they seem really out of
touch I'm with you I think hence not
only misspoke obviously but I think he's
being willfully taken out of context by
people who were attacking him but even
on that front
I get why people are doing it to me it's
kind of like when somebody calls someone
else a racist slur maybe that means that
the person who's using the slur is a
racist but very often it doesn't
sometimes you call somebody a racist
slurp someone could you imagine someone
called me a guido or something like that
a guinea I don't know what they call me
my God could you imagine not very often
people would not do that
because they hate Italian people very
often they will use that kind of a slur
because they don't like me and so
they'll just because they don't like me
already they're just going to attack me
any way they can and I kind of think
that's what's going on with Pence here I
don't think people really believe that
Mike Pence says the American interest is
not my case right right I think they
don't like Pence already they don't like
him for whatever he's done in his career
they don't like him for the vision that
he's presenting for the country and so
they're just going to attack him anyway
it's it's just it's it's moving in the
opposite direction of of what the the
critics are saying right now but the end
result is the same the Pence campaign
just looks dead in the water right and
then at that point just because of the
way the internet works now it doesn't
matter if the rest of the half hour with
Tucker is 99 on point that's the clip
that's going to go and the rest of it is
irrelevant I'm not saying that it was
but that's just sort of the nature of
the internet Brian why do you think he
Pence is even running I I genuinely do
not know one person that is a Mike Pence
for president supporter I know a lot of
people in politics
well I think that there are probably a
couple candidates who fall into that ASA
Hutchinson it would might be another one
there are folks that really don't have a
base of support in this country and
frankly haven't really put forward a
good compelling argument why they're
there I think pence in his mind thinks
that he's the adult in the room and so
he's going to be this sort of reaganess
figure that's going to stand up take the
Republican Party back from sort of its
Insanity as he would say and you know
take this country in a different and
better Direction much like Reagan did
but times have changed this isn't you
know 1980 or 1988 the countries changed
the Republican party has changed we are
in a much I think angrier country I
think if you look at a lot of the
polling folks say we are on the wrong
track we want a very different uh set of
of people in the United States uh White
House and the Congress but also more
importantly I think that the
administrative State we call the Deep
State people understand that this
country is not working and they want a
little bit of spit on that fastball when
we have politicians talking about
changing it and Pence is like that
fellow who's had maybe two or three
shots he although he doesn't drink he
sits down and he tells us you know how
he's going to fix the country in this
very calm way and I don't think too many
people want that I think we want a
little more fire brand to to reflect the
moment of people being very upset and
very angry about the direction of the
country the best I can think of or come
up with I guess related to Pence running
is that he wants to somehow remove the
stain of whatever he thinks the ending
with Trump was and he thinks this is the
way to do it but I don't know that that
fully drives but uh Knowles I know you
haven't taken a full position on the
Trump DeSantis thing you like certain
things about both of them I guess
dislike certain things about both of
them but I think Trump really missed an
opportunity to show up there and sit
down with Tucker a guy who he really
aligns with on a lot of stuff Tucker
obviously likes Trump on the Ukraine
stuff they're almost completely eye to
eye do you think he missed an
opportunity there because it would have
been good and by the way I took Tucker's
credit I think he probably would have
hit him on some things that maybe they
don't see eye to eye on
he missed a little bit of opportunity he
missed a little bit of potential upside
but he sidestepped a lot of downside and
so I think it was probably a smart move
for Trump not to show up I think it was
smart for Chris Christie not to show up
I'm the last person in America who's
still waiting on the chrysosons
but Christy's got whatever he's got
three percent call it and Christy knew
that if he showed up there's maybe a
small chance he could have increased
that to five percent but there's a big
chance he could have sent it down to
zero percent like ASA Hutchinson and
Mike Pence did and so Christy avoided it
and then he he mouthed off about it
later on on the Sunday shows Trump had a
similar strategy Trump right now is
about 30 points up in the field he
stands to gain a little bit but he also
opens himself up to a huge amount of
risk even with Tucker who is broadly
allied with him but we know from those
Fox News Dominion texts that Tucker has
complained about Trump before that
Tucker has criticized Trump and so if
the polls were tighter I think Trump
would have had to show up now he didn't
Ronda Santa showed up he did himself a
lot of good I think he really performed
very well I think Nikki Haley actually
performed pretty well also though she's
much much further down in the polls but
this is the the trouble right now for
the state of the field and especially if
you're Ron DeSantis everybody is playing
this safe Trump is playing it safe
desantis's campaign in many ways is
playing it safe Vivek ramaswami is
probably the only guy who's not playing
it safe and it's why you're seeing a lot
of movement on his numbers uh the other
candidates probably not even worth a
mention because they're just all stuck
down there in single digits and so the
problem especially for desantises if he
continues to play it safe Trump's the
nominee barring an indictment and
frankly even with an indictment probably
he could be the nominee so they've got
to do something because if everyone just
keeps playing according to the rule book
right now the race is over yeah by the
way I agree with that to a certain
extent I don't know about over but I
agree with that to an extern a certain
extent he's got to kind of do some new
things so he did go on Tapper yesterday
he's going on Megyn Kelly that took a
long time to happen I think he should go
on Rogan I think he should go on The
View etc etc Donald Trump did not do
nothing that weekend he did go to the
big Turning Point annual conference uh
and here's a bit of his speech that was
only the beginning with your support in
2024 we are going to put America First
like never before and we are going to
finish the job that we so successfully
started
you know many people it was four years
but many people say it was one of the
most successful presidencies ever some
people say it was the most successful
presidency when I get back into the Oval
Office I will totally obliterate the
Deep State they will be obliterated
[Applause]
I don't know some of it again I voted
for him and I like him in a lot of
respects it just it's starting to seem
like this rerun that I've seen a million
times before but but Brian this concept
of that he'll get the Deep State this
time look he did a pretty freaking good
job as president especially the those
first two and a half years but in the
end he did award fouchy on the way out
the the Deep State seemed to have gotten
him as a as a former three-letter guy in
the CIA like do you think he knows what
he's up against does anyone really know
what he's up against well I don't think
he or any of these guys yeah fair look I
think in 2016 he certainly didn't know I
think the folks around him didn't have
any understanding of how bad it was
going to be and then he was basically
thrown into the wood chipper by these
guys at the FBI the agency and others
and so I think that he's been pretty
burned pretty heavily I think everybody
in the country knows how bad those
organizations have got those mid-level
those senior level individuals the James
comey's the Christopher Rays now we've
got some more reports from inspector
generals and special counsels that said
these guys are to no good so I I think
that there is now a wind at his back for
the conversation that the country has to
have and has been happening that we need
some pretty serious reform and we need
to toss a lot of folks out of office so
the real question is going to be does he
have the support on Capitol Hill to do
that you know that's going to be yeah I
think something I'll be looking for
certainly the next day after we all vote
who controls the house and the Senate
because that power of the purse is going
to be very important I know that he's
looking at his team we're looking at
executive orders to toss out a lot of of
you know mid-level you know Folks at
their will or their whim maybe they'll
be able to do that I think it's called
schedule F or something and iterate the
point is you know they're they're
looking at doing uh what they need to do
to clean the join up um it's got to be
done I think most of us now understand
that does he have the Congressional you
know back backing to do that
particularly with the power of the purse
that's the part that I think really that
will shape this whole conversation can
he actually do what he's saying he wants
to do Michael putting aside the power of
the person whether the Republicans have
Congress and Senate and all the stuff do
you think he can staff with the right
people that can do this thing I mean
that's what I'm actually it look I have
said this a million times even though I
obviously am supporting DeSantis if at
the end of this Trump is President and
DeSantis is my Governor I will be fine I
guarantee you I will be fine and that
way and I will gladly vote for Trump and
that will be it my concern with the
Trump presidency at this point though is
that he will get there and nobody is
going to want to work for him for good
reason
personnel has been a problem for Trump
he's had some real stars but it by his
own admission he's had some real
plunkers in there and and so my most out
of the box thought if the polls remain
as they are if Trump becomes the nominee
I know a lot of people are saying
DeSantis should be VP I think we both
know neither of those guys
at the very least DeSantis as Chief of
Staff would not be the worst idea
because the the real shining Mark for
DeSantis here is he knows personnel and
he knows how to wield power and he's
done it on a smaller stage in Florida
but that would be the thing that Trump
is talking about right now how do you
wield power on the personnel and the
issue is the Deep State depending on how
you count the bureaucracy just employees
for the federal government is like two
million people it is just so many many
people even Under the Umbrella of the
DHS you're talking about a quarter
million people and so in order to make
substantial change in there you would
have to switch out forty to fifty
thousand people just to start to get the
engine and Machinery moving in the right
direction again an ordinary president
swaps out four to five thousand people
so we're talking about a drop in the
bucket and and Trump doesn't really need
to prove anything right now I guess
because he's so far up in the polls but
if those numbers start to decline and if
a number two candidate starts to get a
little bit closer then I think the
biggest thing Trump is going to have to
prove
is how he can get
a sufficient number of people to say
nothing of the sufficient quality of
people into those positions to actually
take back the the Deep State and so far
we haven't we haven't really seen that
plan yeah for the record I I think
there's no chance in hell DeSantis
leaves Florida to go be Chief of Staff
or attorney general or anything like
that I also think full position in the
world but you're probably right yeah but
I also think that's why what Trump did
with Kaylee mcineny was so bad because
it was like she was such an obvious
All-Star for him it's one thing you go
after Christopher Ray and Coleman nobody
cares about those like those types of DC
people Swamp People but Kaylee it was
just too much of an All-Star to go after
but all right we'll leave it at that
let's let's move on to what I think
we're all going to completely defend
Trump on uh which is another freaking
indictment this week another week
another indictment we've got some info
from the daily wire you know these
people nulls have you ever heard of them
I've heard of them I've passed them in
the hallway sometimes but yeah all right
here we go uh former president Donald
Trump said Tuesday he's been informed by
a special counsel Jackson myth that he
is a criminal Target of a Washington D.C
grand jury investigating his alleged
efforts to overturn the 2020 election
Trump announced on Truth social that he
got a Target letter Sunday night in
which Smith's office offered him the
opportunity to appear before the grand
jury this week the development indicates
another indictment could be on the way
although it does not say what the
charges does not say What charges Trump
would face Brian this strikes me as the
swampiest Swamp stuff ever there's
obviously going to be more of these by
the way we know something's coming in
Georgia I don't know what they're going
after here what the indictment's for I
mean we know Trump was saying be
peaceful blah blah blah
but here we are ah look I at this point
fundamentally I think the American
people are looking at their Department
of Justice and asking the question do I
trust that the doj or that the FBI do I
trust that they will do their job
without fear or favor that they're going
to be nonpartisan and at this point I
think most of us have decided uh well if
you look at the polls they believe that
Biden and his family have gotten
preferential treatment so the the doj
and the bureau's cases just don't stand
up to that smell test most Americans
just don't support it the partisans you
know particularly on the left that
they're they're going to just embrace it
because they hate Trump but it is wildly
dangerous I think it's very clear that
this doj is out of control we have more
IRS agents who are stepping up as
whistleblowers you know confirming that
and I think that this just puts more
wind to the back of trump and his his
claim that he's being persecuted and
prosecuted for partisan reasons and it
helps him make the case to the American
people that we got to clean the joint up
if we can probably debate whether or not
he's going to be able to do that
particularly with the Deep state or
ejecting as you uh Knowles just said you
know 40 50 000 people but he has that
that the principle at his back and at
his side to say yes I am the persecuted
they're coming from me and then they're
coming from you
Michael call me a conspiratorial
cynicist but is it possible that these
indictments keep coming because that's
what's keeping Trump in the news and the
Machine wants Trump as the nominee we
know that every time one of these comes
down the pike his numbers go up that
seems to be the thing that keeps the
numbers afloat
well there there are two reads on it one
is yeah the media want Trump because
they think they can beat Trump uh and
and the liberal establishment wants that
that's why they keep indicting him the
other one is they see him as a genuine
threat that's why they tried to
undermine his administration that's why
they changed all the election rules in
2020 and so they're doing it really to
to harm him in the race either way you
read it
the the difficult fact for governor
DeSantis and for the other candidates is
it it just makes the race about Trump
and we can pull our hair out about that
and we can say well it shouldn't be
about trump it should be about this
issue or that issue but in war and in
politics your enemy gets a say and so
they're playing their card and they're
saying that this is all about Trump and
this indictment by the way is more
egregious than the other ones when they
go after him for some fantasy that a
lunatic lady made up about Bergdorf
Goodman's when they go after him for the
mementos he kept from the White House
when they go whatever it's unprecedented
but it's crazy this one however is
they're saying that because he contested
the results of the election he's
committed some kind of a felony this is
not without precedent in 1876 you had a
hotly contested race between Rutherford
B Hayes the Republican Sam till then the
Democrat this came down to a back room
deal between the Republicans and the
Democrats Hayes gets the the election
the the Republicans pull out of the
South for reconstruction it was a
constitutional crisis though it was and
they came up with a grand bargain here
this is not unprecedented but at extreme
moments of hotly debated racism as you
had in 2020 when they changed all the
election rules what the Democrats are
saying now is
we are going to criminalize politics we
are going to criminalize raising
questions about an election particularly
a really radical one that threatens not
just Trump not just the Republican party
that threatens the whole electoral
system that we have and by the way how
many Democrats and the entire freaking
corporate press were questioning the
results of the election when Trump won
the first time or how many Democrats
were on the record saying the George W
Bush was an illegitimate president uh
because of bush Vigor and all that stuff
but I thought there was an actual nice
moment of politics this week related to
Trump and DeSantis which is kind of rare
these days this was at a DeSantis event
a couple days ago in South Carolina a
trump voter a previous Trump voter after
listening to DeSantis and I think
there's something to this
invited to
to come to listen to you
one representative of moss I'm a very
hardcore Trump supporter
but I know
he made me stop and think a minute
because my love for president Trump
comes from all the despair all the
things that he's been through has served
as our president of the United States
and he did a good job
but all the things I'm thinking more
with my heart and my sorrow and my love
for him and for this country but now I
have this is the most important vote
that we're going to have and I have to
think more with my mind and what's best
for this country and you did an
excellent job and I certainly God bless
you thank you
[Music]
and I appreciate that
and um you know I agree with you I
appreciate what president Trump did uh
how they treated him with things like
Russia collusion was a disgrace and and
he was treated wrong uh he was treated
in ways that were unconstitutional uh
but here's the thing the question for us
now is what are we going to do about it
and we need to end the weaponization of
government I will get that done it's not
about me it's about you it's about me
standing up for you and standing up for
this Constitution and restoring this
country to what the founding fathers
Envision and and we will we will get it
done we will be focused we will be
disciplined and we will make it happen
Michael let me start with you on that
one I thought it was a nice moment
because I thought that that woman in a
very emotional way captured what a lot
of people feel right now which is
there's a huge appreciation for Trump he
doled out more red pills than any of us
could for the rest of our lives all of
that kind of thing and then she's saying
but I but I sort of feel like moving on
and that DeSantis then basically was
like I appreciate him too I think I'm
the guy and to me that's I get primaries
we're all going to shred each other but
to me that strikes the tone that I
actually think most people want to hear
what do you think it was a great moment
the whole event was really good for
DeSantis even in in the way that he
reacted to the news of the indictment
and he was reacting on the fly but but
he did so in a way that was gracious and
still has this problem though which is
we're all still talking about exchange
which is heartfelt she says I'm going to
vote for Yuna it's all still about Trump
so I I think it was really good and he
the thing he struck on that really could
resonate and really could be a new path
for his campaign is if he Taps into what
Trump did in 2016 which is it's not
about me it's about you Hillary says I'm
with her I say I'm with you and you just
totally take that ego out of it you take
that personality out of it that can be
really charming and persuasive and and
offer a choice not an echo if DeSantis
continues to run his Trump 2.0 bigger
better faster stronger he's going to
lose because even if New Coke tastes
better than old Coke people want old
Coke they want the OG if DeSantis really
strikes this difference and you see him
starting to do that in this answer then
maybe you've got a real alternative and
then you've maybe got a viable path to
the nomination yeah what do you think
about that Brian that that makes sense
to me well I think that's very smart I
would also add one thing that that
beautiful woman I think represents
something very important that I think of
a candidate could capture and spread
this message that so many of us feel so
disheartened so disillusioned that
either we want to just be reflexive with
our emotions or we just want to give up
and what she did in that moment is say
actually I I'm still here thinking with
my mind I still want to be reasonable I
want to be thoughtful and that's very
inspirational I think for a lot of
people who have given up or just want to
think uh or not think rather and just
Embrace their their heart and their
emotions so what a cool moment that that
was for so many people who I think have
this this sort of dispirited feeling in
this country she really I think stood up
for for a lot of folks who have given up
and that's a cool message that I think a
lot of candidates should really Embrace
is we need more of that please
yeah and that's why I wanted to show it
for the second time this week because
it's like we all repeatedly show
somebody getting owned and demolished
and destroyed and perhaps perhaps there
is another way out of this thing but
let's jump over to uh the guy on the
other side who ain't being treated that
well by the corporate press and the
mainstream media and everybody else
actually they're treating him like one
of us uh yes I'm talking about RFK Jr I
had him on the show a couple days ago
and we talked about conspiracy theories
and slow motion reality and time release
truth and all that stuff I asked people
to come up with some of your dangerous
ideas and nobody seems to really know
what they are but that doesn't stop the
New York Times yeah and all of my
conspiracy theories as it turns out have
come true they're no longer theories
they're you know they're now proven
hypotheses but I do wonder about it I
you know I was thinking about this this
morning because the the this kind of
this hail storm of negative publicity
about I mean really kind of not it goes
beyond like hit pieces it's to be just
is you know poisonous vitriol that it's
coming from all the Legacy Media from
the Atlantic Monthly from New York
Magazine New York or the Washington Post
and the New York Times from Vanity Fair
and they all kind of use the same
talking points and uh and they also are
not accurate and that's one of the
reasons it doesn't trouble me is because
it's it's just it's just inaccuracies
distortions
Brian it seems like uh he's just getting
a dose of what Republicans have been
getting a dose of for a long time
yeah so here's what's so fascinating to
me about this you know we talked earlier
about how Trump didn't show up because
at some level he didn't want to punch
down he's so far ahead Biden and his
team and frankly those around him that
they're punching as it were down they're
trying to take this guy out even though
he is dramatically behind in the polls
if you believe most of them but the so
the point is that they actually view him
as a threat there's something about him
that is very frightening to the Democrat
Party so that to me I think is perhaps
the most interesting development over
the past week or so which is this guy is
resonating at some level that scares a
living crap out of the Biden campaign
and other Democrats to me there's
something else going on here that he's
tapping into and I think that that's
really important to acknowledge Michael
you debate Democrats all the time and go
to college events where you often open
up the floor I do it too I always say if
you disagree with me you come up first
you you do that stuff all the time I
know it's getting harder and harder to
find sort of legit people to debate with
the fact that this guy is obviously not
going to be allowed on the stage with
Biden they're never going to have him
Primary in the first place that's one
thing but further in the conversation I
said to him are you in any contact with
the Democratic party the DNC no that was
the answer one word no does that tell
you all you need to know about the
Democrats the Republicans for all their
faults when Trump was the Renegade in
they didn't stop him he ran right
through and took over the Democrats are
full on stopping the Renegade and by the
way they've done this before cue Bernie
Sanders and think about who the Renegade
is the Renegade is activity is Jack
Kennedy's nephew Bobby Kennedy's son
he's in his own right a major figure on
the left for the past 30 40 years now
but because he contradicts their
narrative on a few issues and more
importantly because he threatens their
power now the guy's totally out forget
about what the DNC is saying about him
and Biden look at what his own sister
says about him Bobby Kennedy is filmed
at a dinner
mentioning a scientific theory what does
he say he says there's a a fear now that
there are ethnically targeted bio
weapons which is just true that's been
written about in magazines for years and
he says and there is a theory about
kovid that it's harsher on certain races
than it is on other races
also true you can look up the scientific
paper all the man is saying is there is
a theory which you can read in a
scientific paper that's published a
couple years ago that this this has
different effects uh with different
genetic backgrounds is called an
anti-semite a vile racist by not only
the White House his own sister sister
Carrie Kennedy it reminds you that on
the Democrat side
on the left broadly
there is no more important tie than
political convenience and that includes
immediate family
and by the way if you think that kovid
was some Grand conspiracy by the Jews
Israel got vaxed more than anybody and
their problem and and sadly will
probably pay the price when it comes to
vaccine injuries and everything else but
let's leave that one there and shift to
the elderly gentleman pretending to be
president of course I'm talking about
Joe Biden uh don't uh worry about Joe
that's at least what Nancy Pelosi say in
these days he's now his grandfather he's
mostly grandfatherly and we should
appreciate that I want to ask
speaker Pelosi about 2024 uh you talked
a lot about President Biden's uh
successful presidency so far all the
points on the board it's a long list I
think arguably uh objectively one can
say he has accomplished a great deal
maybe even historic proportions
um but there's uh the question I have
for you as a
um honoree on the very first 50 over 50
list with Forbes and know your value a
lot of people are talking about the
president's age as a factor in this
especially Republicans
um what do you make of the criticism the
president is getting that he's too old
to have a second term
I think the President should embrace his
age his experience uh what he has the
knowledge that he brings to the job
putting aside uh Nancy Pelosi for just a
moment the way that Mika is tickling his
old balls I'm sorry for the imagery
could really make you barf oh you like
that one
they're a little more uptight over there
at the daily wire but but don't take my
word for any of people might be watching
going Dave you're always hitting him on
his age it's just too much well Biden
did manage to fall asleep while talking
to the Israeli President we brought
Israelis and Palestinians together at a
political level
requirement
and as I
Farm to front
Knowles
the issue is not the age the issue is
not the I'm with Aristotle I think age
and maturity that's good with age comes
wisdom Reagan was old Trump is old the
problem is that the man doesn't function
he was never the sharpest tool in the
shed going back to 1972 when he entered
the Senate and things have gotten
dramatically worse in recent years even
since he left the Obama White House and
if you just see it absolutely everywhere
it's constantly on show so the libs have
tried to resurrect this idea of a virile
Biden they used to do it with dark
Brandon memes now they're doing it with
this leak this leaked report to axios
that Biden he's yelling at his staff and
he gets into the Weeds on the details
and all the policies it's total BS the
guy is asleep the guy's not only asleep
most of the time he's asleep most of the
time that we see him on camera so so
he's declining cognitively and in the
polls this is also why you see a Gavin
Newsom waiting there in the wings
the question right now is who's going to
decide the nominee first the Republican
party or the Democrats yeah I think
that's well said uh Brian what are you
making this thing I agree with Michael
it's not this is not making fun of
someone because of their age he could be
five years older and if he was competent
even if I disagreed with him this would
not be about age this is about literally
falling asleep in front of the president
of another country this is a problem
yeah so look is commander-in-chief your
support your preeminent role in this
country in fact in the world given what
we are as a nation is to protect and
defend and let's think about this from
the perspective of our foreign
adversaries China Russia others even our
allies in Europe they're looking at this
guy and they're saying I don't know if
he's going to make it to tomorrow
the age issue really is as Knowles just
said it's a cognitive concern and my
fear is that a president XI of China who
was talking about taking back Taiwan by
2027. he looks at a very weak the United
States a very weak commander-in-chief
knowing that we are we are knee-deep if
not neck deep in Ukraine we are low on
things like you know Stinger missiles or
some of our 155 artillery and they
strike all right that is the the reality
here when we have a a compromise
commander-in-chief whether it be his son
or or all those Shenanigans or his
cognitive abilities this really matters
to have a sharp person in the white
house and we don't got that Knowles can
I give you another conspiracy theory
that we can end on I want your both of
your takes on this one which mine is
that they obviously know something's
wrong with him he's OB he's being
drugged there's simply no doubt about it
doctors in some staffers there's a
certain closed amount of people that
know something and it seems to me at
some point someone is going to say
something because it will have gotten to
the point one way or another that it
will be so bad that not everyone will
want to be taken down by this thing and
whether it's a low-level staffer who saw
something go on or a piece of paper that
has the medication list or whatever he's
snorting Adderall or cocaine or whatever
this cannot last forever and it will
break
possible I mean listen some people
really deny till they die we didn't
figure out that LBJ stole the 1948
Senate race until like 1991. so these
political Secrets can last for a long
time the the worst aspect of this is not
that something is being hidden or
something might come out the more
depressing aspect is let's say it came
out tomorrow and let's say Biden were
still up in the polls
would anybody care let's say it came out
to discover being drugged left and right
he's got 10 different types of cognitive
decline
would the Democrats care I think they
already knew that in 2020. I think they
all knew he was on the decline but as
long as they can affix him to
marionette's Strings and have a
semi-warm body sitting in the Oval
Office from which they can get their
judges get their apparatchics get their
policies through I just don't think they
care yeah that's probably right you
think because they're all going to be
like oh you know who the VP is
we're in a lot we're in a lot of trouble
here Brian bring us home
my goodness gracious I tell you what
what an error what a time to live in
right now we we have a compromised
president on multiple levels we got
parties who are busted and broken we
have a corporate press who doesn't give
a darn about much of anything other than
making money in their pride and egos
it's a tough time so this election's a
big one it's an important one a local
level state level Federal we've got a
lot of work to do we got a lot of stuff
broken we can do it like that lady said
talking to Governor DeSantis like she
wants to think with her her head and her
heart so that's a good thing that gives
me hope
Strong finish for the for the newest
podcaster out of the three of us I have
to say that was quite a finale of the
show uh Brian Michael I thank you guys
are welcome back anytime of course links
to your stuff right down below have a
great weekend everybody
foreign foreign foreign